[Musique]
non non on n'en a pas encore marbre
nans-sous-sainte-anne mais on a décidé
aujourd'hui de faire un petit pas de
côté un gros même direction la suisse
pour aller voir des menhirs de la route
comme du bord du lac de neuchâtel c'est
insoupçonnable et pourtant à yverdon au
lieu-dit la promenade des anglaises se
cache un site classé monument historique
les manières de klein dit nous sommes
dans un losange qui mesure à peu près
110 mètres de long pour une cinquantaine
de mètres de large et ce losange il est
délimité par deux alignements principaux
de menhirs et puis quatre groupes
et ça ça reflète vraiment l'état dans
lequel on les a trouvés
quand ces gros blocs de pierre sont
découverts coucher et enfouis dans le
sol en 1887
on ne comprend pas encore que ce sont
des menhirs ce n'est qu'un siècle plus
tard après deux campagnes de fouilles
pour les mettre au jour qu'ils seront
authentifiées et redresser on est à
l'époque néolithique on va construire
des maisons le long du littoral et ses
menhirs s'inscrivent en fait dans cette
période on a plusieurs interprétations
possibles non une interprétation
justement religieuse de rencontre de la
population venait là pour faire des
cérémonies et ses menhirs ont un sens
ici parce que dix font partie d'un
ensemble
c'est un site qui est bien fréquentée
qui à terme elle aussi à la fois pour le
côté historique pour le côté énergétique
pour que certaines personnes et même
pour certains sources d'inspiration
comme pour l'artiste photographe cédric
brogniart ouais je viens simplement
m'imprégner en fait d'une mémoire du
passé c'est pierre en fait je vais
chercher l'endroit où je vois le visage
vous est l'impression que on rentre en
contact ici
eh bien j'ai la sensation d'y voir comme
une sorte de coiffes un peu pointus
comme ça comme un chapeau et puis on
voit incliné paul un petit peu sur la
gauche comme un bras d'accord le connaît
aux mailles excès de très élancée de
traits masculins comme les jeux les
nommer de chamade j'ai utilisé des noms
qui existaient yassin hussin sponsors
l'été dernier il a réalisé avec les
habitants d'yverdon une performance
collective à partir de ces clichés
imprimé sur papier grandeur nature tout
un chacun était invité à prendre le
pinceau l'exercise donc avec le pinceau
viennent sur les zones grises pour
contraster les arrivées au noir il avait
ensuite aux photographes y est et pas un
processus de lithographie on retrouve
l'empreinte du menhir réduit 5 à 6 soit
ce qu'apporte le côté artistique en fait
sur quelque chose de scientifique pour
son travail cédric n'a choisi que
quelques pièces sur les 45 que compte le
site
des statues menhirs preuve qu'il y a
plus de six millénaires on les façonnait
déjà mais autrement c'était une
technique qui se faisait en étant d un
des coins donc des aliments en voit
qu'on a un maître dans la faille en fait
de la roche avec l'eau le coin à les
gonfler et szalai permettent en fait de
déliter laroche et puis après il allait
retravailler en fait la surface qu'on
n'a aucune idée du nombre de personnes
qui viennent ici chaque année aucune
idée c'est vraiment totalement ouvert
une fréquentation animal c'est
certainement puisqu'on aborde une
réserve naturelle mais c'est totalement
ouvert totalement libre c'est un petit
bijou que la ville a son site qui est
fascinant et qui en même temps des
paysans ci a presque un petit air de
bretagne au bord du lac de neuchâtel
et c'est un site qui est rare aussi
puisqu'il est considéré comme le plus
grand site mégalithique de suisse quand
même quand même
et